Kevin Hart Fandango wants to play a
little game with you called this or that
this or that is one of my favorite game
is it really do you play it all the time
I'll play it all the time at home with
your kids I literally do top two best
games as you can are you ready we're
gonna go Philly on you Philly
cheesesteaks are soft pretzels I'm gonna
go Philadelphia cheesesteaks okay Pat's
or Geno's I'm gonna go genome-wide you
know why you're just in on Pat's Pat's
is good but you walk out of pants with a
smell that stays on you for three days
that's the only thing it's good the
cheese thing is amazing but the smell
that you take out with you you smell
like a cheese steak for three days it's
not where that just doesn't come off
water ice are tasty cakes oh my goodness
that's tough what what season is it the
summer oh you're getting all fancy on
call you if you're gonna be Philadelphia
then I mean I gotta go full fledged
Illadelph let's go summer this summer's
I want to go water ice yeah I made that
obvious yes I know what else okay
italian market or reading terminal
reading terminal the reason why i say
reading it's cuz i was younger my mom
would buy so much meat you know ya'll
said I'm a little boy and she would make
me carry this meat we like I remember
paper bags busing plastic bags busing
there was you better get it you better
figure it out now this is low frail bull
hey walking getting on a train getting
off the train walking to the house so I
have some have some very fond memories
of reading DJ jazzy jeff and the fresh
prince or boys to men I think I lost my
virginity to a boys a min song I'm go
boys the men yeah who Dada no that's a
first time question mmm dolphins are
snakes dolphins outie I don't like
neither but I have cheers OH dolphins
white bunnies are dogs white bunnies
white bunnies snowball has changed my
outlook on all bunnies I love bunnies
now that's the secret life of pets so
the secret life of pets or the public
life of Kevin Hart public life of Kevin
Hart all day why cuz it's a non-stop
movie cuz it's real and I opened it up
to where everybody can see
this isn't a facade this is who I am I
think that's the beauty of social media
and what it allows us to do you get to
see me on all platforms all levels Kevin
Hart thank you for playing oh thank you
you